la sesión ha sido accidentada
congresistas de Perú libre agrupación
ligada al expresidente Pedro Castillo
protestaron contra el Primer Ministro
Alberto taruela y su gabinete con
pancartas y gritos rechazaron a otaruela
por las violencias producida en las
últimas horas en la región puno donde se
han producido 18 muertos al respecto el
Primer Ministro taruela anunció el toque
de queda por tres días en la región puno
y dijo que el gobierno de Dina boluarte
no va a aceptar el chantaje de la
violencia y dijo que van a emplear todo
el rigor de la ley para proteger a los
peruanos en esa línea del Primer
Ministro ha hecho importantes anuncios y
tras también señalar que el gobierno va
a destrabar nueve proyectos mineros por
más de diez mil quinientos millones de
dólares Alberto tarola ha solicitado el
de confianza para su gabinete de
ministros Francisco ya lo decíamos ha
sido una jornada también de paro
nacional allí en Perú principalmente en
puno como usted lo ha dicho es donde la
situación es más complicada 18 personas
muertas Cuál es el balance hasta el
momento allí en el sur del país que más
dicen las autoridades
hasta el momento la superintendencia de
transporte registra 55 puntos de
tránsito e interrumpidos diez vías
nacionales bloqueadas que afectan a seis
regiones del Perú se reporta
manifestaciones en diferentes lugares
del país Mientras tanto en el sur del
Perú en la localidad de Apurímac
manifestantes atacaron con piedras a una
corte al mismo tiempo en Arequipa 200
pobladores bloquean la carretera
Panamericana de sur y otras vías con
piedras y neumáticos mientras que
juliaca representa la mayor atención
donde se produjeron las muertes en las
últimas horas al respecto amnistía
internacional ha hecho un llamado al
gobierno peruano en lo que denomina un
uso excesivo de la fuerza y le ha pedido
que se paralice este tipo de acciones y
también le ha exigido a las autoridades
peruanas Investigar la supuesta
violaciones a los derechos humanos desde
que se iniciaron las protestas que en
este país llevan más de cuatro dec enas
de fallecidos